the first animated series to feature
Spider-Man was simply titled Spider-Man
and it aired on ABC from 1967 to 1970.
the 1981 series Spider-Man and His
Amazing Friends featured Spider-Man
teaming up with Iceman and Firestar the
1981 series Spider-Man was a second take
on the webslinger that aired alongside
the previously mentioned Spider-Man and
His Amazing Friends the 1994 series
Spider-Man the Animated Series was a
critical and Commercial Success running
for a total of five seasons Spider-Man
Unlimited was a loose sequel to the
popular Spider-Man the Animated Series
and featured a new setting new
characters and a new costume for
Spider-Man Spider-Man the new animated
series was Loosely based on the Sam
Raimi films The Spectacular Spider-Man
was a modernized take on the character
that was heavily inspired by the Stan
Lee and Steve ditko runs of the comics
Ultimate Spider-Man was a Disney XD
Series with a modernized take on the
character that was heavily influenced by
the Ultimate Spider-Man comic book
series Marvel Spider-Man is another
Disney XD Series that's heavily inspired
by the Tom Holland Spider-Man films
Spider-Man into the spider-verse is the
first animated film in the Spider-Man
franchise